all right
so Jennifer you were here how long ago
it's been like over a year
almost
a year almost a year and you were deep
into crack
yes yes
I was on crack alcohol what was it tell
me describe that lifestyle what was your
typical day back then so on crack
um actually on the streets
yes yeah I had just relapsed
um I was on the Run
I
yeah I was in a really dark place
I um
man I I couldn't see the light at the
end of the tunnel
I uh I was doing what I had to do every
day to get what I needed and I'm which
is what I'm the kind of uh I'm I commit
crimes so
whatever it takes I
um you know I it could be anything from
putting a gun to your head to go get it
or
walk into Walmart and taking the whole
basket
um or sex
no not not recently I haven't done I
haven't had to sell my body
oh in about 20 years but um
but I might have her go do it for me you
know I might have somebody else go do it
for me or I might uh pretend I'm gonna
do it and take somebody's money you know
um which is just as dangerous you know
it's just as dangerous to get in
somebody's car and act like you're gonna
have sex with him and Rob him
you know um considering I'm a three
Striker and
you know I put myself in a lot of uh
situations especially being downtown you
know
um you meet some real characters down
here and
that's what I was doing
and
when I came here
I think I was about two months uh two
weeks into a relapse and I had that 15
year joint suspension
and I had a case I was fighting
and I'm gonna tell you Mark I didn't
think I was gonna make it back I didn't
think I was going to make it back I just
got six months of sobriety yesterday six
months yes and what what steered you in
that direction
so I was arrested
um
I went to court
I fought a case out of San Fernando
my program uh I'm going to a drug
treatment program and they fought for me
and
what's the name of the drug treatment
Licata I go through Lakota yeah
l-a-c-a-d-a locata
um being that I'm 42 a three Striker and
I'm going to tell you something
everybody's given up on me my family
everybody's given up on me and
they did it they they went to bat for me
um month after month in court they
fought for me
and
man you know being that they fought for
me I just I just made a conscious
decision to fight for myself
and at the end of the day what ended up
happening was um San Fernando offered me
six years
and the goddess said no they said we
want her back we want her she's she
she's capable of being sober
and I got it so uh November 22nd I was
released from jail
I went into a residential facility I
stayed for 60 days
and now I'm doing sober living and
outpatient how how important was it to
have somebody who believed in you or
just was behind you like that you know
what it
when everybody else in the world gives
up on you and
strangers from a program Believe In You
It's unexplainable
it's unexplainable because at this point
in my life I just I felt forgotten
and it's so important it's so important
and it just gave me that extra like
I just have the will like
I mean I'm I'm running a program of
honesty right now like
there's nothing that I won't do I'll
I'll go the extra length to keep doing
what I'm doing just to make it like I
want to make it I want to reach back out
and I want to help
like I'm I'm fighting for my life I'm
fighting for my life in every single way
and I'm I'm gonna do it period it's so
it's so encouraging to hear some hear
you speak like this because yes you were
just one of the many who just were lost
in the drugs and the chaos you know I've
watched my I've watched my video back
and I I refer to like
being uncomfortable in my skin
um I kind of normalized being on drugs
and
I'm not that today like
I'm at peace I have this inner peace
this
like it's okay today like if I don't
I wake up in the morning and like if I
don't have money it's okay like
I'm looking forward I'm actively looking
for a job I'm I'm trying to get into
school
all these these little
roadblocks they're okay because I know
no matter what I'm gonna do this I don't
have to turn to drugs and alcohol I have
the support system I have my mental
health Team like I'm on board with my
mental health everything that I'm that
suggested of the program everything that
my
that Lakota is recommending me to do I'm
just doing it and it's working out
and I just feel phenomenal I feel
phenomenal
and I got you know I stay in contact I
got a sponsor I go to meetings I do
everything that they recommend and it's
working out it's just working out it's
got to impact your your everything right
everything and then these Little
Miracles they happen I called I called
my my grandma the other day I haven't
talked to her in two years she answered
the phone
how does that happen
it just works out just little things are
working out
you know just every day I just don't use
no matter what just don't use how
difficult was it to put down crack
well when you go to jail it's not
difficult at all
how difficult is it to not pick up it's
not difficult because when I left
I was miserable
I was miserable you know what I mean I
was I was miserable
there there's no joy in
being cold and hungry and nothing to eat
and no place to shower and people
stealing your food you know your clothes
and your food and you know I'm sitting
on this corner fist fighting girls for
what like
you know ducking and dodging and like
I'm 42. you know what I mean I haven't
met my my two-year-old granddaughter I
haven't seen my kids in two years like
I keep hurting the people that I love
the most but most of all I keep hurting
me
and I like me I like me enough
to keep trying no matter what when I
fall dust myself up and try again
but I I believe I won't have to dust off
no more like this time Jennifer's got
this
Jennifer's got this
I wanna I wanna grow up and be like you
and help people
it's so refreshing to hear like somebody
who's recovered
just talk about their life
I'll just be so into it and so like
optimistic and positive I want it Mark I
want it I want something better I want I
would watch this video I would watch my
old video and I just couldn't wait to
come tell you like Mark
I'm here like I'm alive like I'm not
going to be one of those stories of like
she passed away like she's in the gutter
like I just wanted to tell you like I'm
here like I I'm here I'm sober and I'm
trying and like
let's share this story let's share this
story like she's she's here like I'm
here
I'm here and I'm gonna keep coming to
tell you that I'm here and I'm making it
and it can happen for anybody
you know yeah I believe it I believe it
even the worst the worst the worst of
the worst and I mean I've been an addict
for over 26 years
you know I've been I I've done it all
I've I've prostituted I'm a three
Striker I've I I have a child a product
of rape you know we can the list goes on
the list goes on I I've I've witnessed
murders I've I've I'm a gang member you
know we can go on the list goes on of
things that have happened to Jennifer
Jennifer has witnessed and been involved
with a lot of ugly things I'm I'm from
the east side of the low bottoms of
South Central
you know I have been gorilla pimped I've
been all kind of stuff we can tell you
all the bad things but now I'm here to
tell you the great ones the great ones
that are about to come I have a higher
Powers I tell everybody I have a big God
I believe in him and I trust him and
every day he shows me that he's gonna
help me
you know and it's just
you know um I will always be an addict
but I believe that I can recover
you know Perfectly Imperfect
Jennifer what'd you say is the most
important lesson you've learned after
all this this journey
nothing's permanent
you know it's the way you perceive
things the way you look at it
I look at I look at life is I'm still
growing
the most important lesson is everything
can be changed
you don't ever have to make a situation
a permanent one unless you want it to be
I want my permanent situation to be
something that I make it and I and I
still have I have goals I want to go to
school
I want to be present in my children's
life
but I don't want to be that Mom that
goes away every time I want to be a
present healthy virtuous woman somebody
that's there
you know somebody they can depend on
somebody they can call and I answer
not someone that sold her phone because
she needed a hit you know I just I wanna
I wanna be a nice person
you know I want to help people too
I want to be able to help myself
you know I just
everything that
I dreamed of I'm gonna make it come true
for myself because I deserve that
I I no longer will settle for the things
that I've settled for in my past
I'm gonna settle
for the great things that I've deserved
my whole life
all the lies that I believed before I no
longer will believe them
wow what a beautiful story
Jennifer I'm proud of you thank you so
great to see so great to see you too
good luck with everything from here
thank you thank you